[Music]
on this Tuesday night a passenger plane
erupts into flames in Tokyo how almost
400 people safely escaped this tragic
crash it was a miracle as Japan recovers
from strong earthquakes what helped the
country avert a bigger
disaster a top Hamas official killed the
potential acts of
Revenge the rich just keep getting
richer The Staggering amount of cash
Canada's top executives are earning and
that's also a new record how it compares
to last year and who made the most plus
he captured cruelty with his camera the
life of fearless photojournalist Peter
magubane global national with Donna FZ
reporting tonight Carolyn
Jarvis good evening and thanks for
joining us five people have been killed
in a fiery crash at Tokyo's hanada
airport after a Japan Airlines flight
carrying hundreds of passengers collided
with a Coast Guard
Plane video from the scene shows the
Airbus a350 engulfed in flames
miraculously all 379 people on board
survived those who died were on the
smaller Coast Guard Plane which was
supposed to deliver Aid to victims of
yesterday's powerful earthquake in
central
Japan a government official says J
flight 516 was trying to land when it
collided on the runway with a smaller -8
aircraft sitting on the tarmac the
larger plane kept moving before coming
to a standstill work is now underway to
figure out how this happened Redmond
Shandon has our top story
tonight from the airport terminal Japan
Airlines flight 516 came into view as an
enormous Fireball hurtling down Runway
sea inside the plane passengers appeared
Cal even as it filled with smoke and as
flames lit up the night sky
outside I felt the airplane tilt to the
side on the runway and felt a big bump
said this passenger recounting what may
have been the moment the Airbus a350
struck a Japanese Coast Guard aircraft
that was getting ready to take
off once the Airbus came to a halt the
12 crew helped all 36 7 passengers to
safety within
minutes the fuselage was engulfed in
fire I can only say it was a miracle
said this passenger we could have died
if we were late
evacuating back at the other end of the
runway the Coast Guard's Canadian built
-8 was a fireball two of its six crew
only the pilot
survived Japan's prime minister fumio
kushida paid tribute to the victims who
had been about to bring Aid to those
affected by Monday's earthquake in
central Japan investigators will be
checking air traffic communication
recordings and looking for any technical
issues to see how one plane ended up in
another's path rarely is there ever just
a single cause so so for an aircraft to
have actually ended up on the runway
there are several checks that that
should have stopped that from happening
the survival of all the commercial
passengers and crew a reminder of how
safe air travel has become even when
things go wrong there were about 34
million commercial flights last year but
only two fatal crashes none were
involving jet aircraft this crash though
a reminder that safety can never be
taken for granted Redmond Channon Global
News
London as mentioned one of those planes
was supposed to deliver Aid to victims
of yesterday devastating earthquake the
magnitude 7.6 Quake took down houses
damaged infrastructure and knocked out
power to more than 40,000 homes 57
people are now confirmed dead Global
Affairs Canada says it hasn't received
any reports of Canadian deaths the full
extent of the damage is still being
assessed and as nugara reports an urgent
search is underway to save people who
may be trapped in the
rubble aerial footage shows widespread
damage in some of the area's hardest hit
from the series of quakes that struck
Japan on New Year's Day leaving an
entire section of wajima City reduced to
ashes the Quakes caused large cracks in
roads and destroyed thousands of homes
complicating search and rescue
efforts the full extent of damage and
death still difficult to
assess the Prime Minister said Japan's
military sent a thousand soldiers to
disaster zones focusing on rescuing
those trapped but beneath the
rubble this resident is back to survey
her wrecked home to find a familiar site
mine not looking more our house was like
this after the last earthquake in 2007
she said we had only just rebuilt our
house it just started very slowly
American Daniel Smith says what he felt
and saw was powerful then it was just a
violent shaking I mean violent
shaking some areas remain without water
power and cell service but Canadian
earthquake experts say the country's
immediate public warnings the general
Public's response followed by official
recovery efforts have helped prevent the
situation from being worse we tend to
have forse sense of security that it
happens somewhere else uh not where we
are both from the design perspectives as
well as preparedness there are a lot of
things we can learn from events like
this people who are not the most
critical for First Responders to reach
should expect to be sheltered ing in
place potentially for weeks if for an
earthquake like this of this magnitude
Japan is the most prepared country in
the world putting into perspective the
scale of damage here as officials warn
of the potential for more Quakes Nara
Global News
Vancouver Russia has Unleashed another
round of deadly bombardments on
Ukraine's two biggest cities a day after
Vladimir Putin vowed to intensify
moscow's
attacks
missiles and drones battered Ukraine's
Capital Region leaving at least four
people dead and dozens more wounded
across several residential neighborhoods
ke's mayor says the attacks also
targeted Power and Water infrastructure
in the city strikes also cause
widespread damage in the northeastern
city of harv where local officials have
reported at least one death in a
statement President Vladimir zalinski
said Russia launched nearly 100 missiles
in its latest attack with Ukrainian
forces shooting down almost 60 of them
in the Middle East the Palestinian red
crescent says its headquarters in Han
Yunis were targeted by an Israeli drone
Attack video shows paramedics scrambling
to reach some of those injured in the
strike at least five people were killed
Israeli officials say they were
targeting areas in the city where Hamas
leaders were believed to be hiding the
Hamas run Health Ministry says more than
200 people have been killed in the past
24 hours pushing the Palestinian death
toll over
22,000 since the October 7th
attack there are renewed concerns
tonight over the risk of a wider Middle
East conflict following the death of a
senior Hamas official in Lebanon the
militant group's number two political
leader is said to have been killed in an
apparent Israeli drone strike in Beirut
marking a potentially significant
escalation of the war Jackson PRCA
reports this is the aftermath of a
suspected Israeli drone strike in
Lebanon that Hamas says killed Deputy
leader salai alarri and two other senior
leaders of its military Wing aruri had
long been designated a global terrorist
by the United States Israel accuses him
of leading lethal attacks on its
citizens immediately there were protests
in the West Bank Hamas called the
assassinations a terrorist act and a
violation of lebanon's
sovereignty Israeli officials wouldn't
respond when asked about the risk of
retaliation including potential
longrange missile attacks launched from
Lebanon by Hezbollah the militant group
claimed to have its finger on the
trigger Israel also faces accusations of
operating inside turkey where officials
claim to have arrested 33 suspected
Israeli spies alleging they plan to
kidnap and kill Hamas officials Israel
has repeatedly been threatened with
serious consequences if it attacked
Hamas members at outside of the
Palestinian territories we are calling
to for maximum restraint from all
parties we don't want
any any rash any rash actions that could
trigger further
violence inside Gaza where violence has
displaced nearly 2 million people
there's no sign of relief at this Tent
City in Rafa food and warmth are in
desperately short
supply not
it would have been better if I had
stayed back in Gaza City and died with
dignity says this
woman the humanitarian situation is
unlikely to get better even as Israel
says it will withdraw thousands of
troops from Gaza in the coming weeks
those troops could well be needed on the
northern border with Lebanon as the
conflict sits on the cusp of a wider and
more dangerous phase Jackson prco Global
News
Washington South Korea's opposition lead
leader has been hospitalized after being
stabbed in the neck at a public event
and a warning some viewers may find this
video disturbing Lee J mang was wrapping
up a visit to the city of Busan when a
man approached Lee pretending to want an
autograph before stabbing him with a
knife the attacker was arrested Lee
underwent surgery and is in intensive
care a new report shows the pay gap
between this country's top CEOs and the
average worker is breaking records
according to the Canadian Center policy
Alternatives the average CEO makes over
$7,000 an hour it takes them just over8
hours to earn
$6,000 what the average worker in Canada
makes in an entire year McKenzie gray
reports on the widening pay Gap as
Canada is Rich get
richer even by Ottawa standards it was a
quiet morning commute but for those who
did come downtown for work by the time
they got their first coffee of the day
Canada's top executives already earned
more than a regular worker will all year
they're just getting more money you'll
never spend that much money in your
lifetime it's impossible to spend that
much money and they're profiting off of
the people on the lower end of the
economy and the money is staggering the
top 100 CEOs in Canada made on average
14.9 million annually in 2022 according
to a new report from the Canadian Center
for policy Alternatives that's a jump of
over
$600,000 from the past year CEOs made uh
just under 250 times what the average
worker makes and that's a lot and that's
also a new record the highest earner
Patrick Doyle of restaurant Brands
International the parent company of
Burger King and Tim Hortons making a
whopping
$151 million but he wasn't paid a single
scent in actual salary his entire
compensation in stock a common Trend
with only 8% of CEO compensation coming
from a regular paycheck the fact that
they can earn so much money from capital
gains makes it all the more rewarding
for them and frankly all the more
insulting for the rest of us who
actually earn money by working for it
companies justify compensation through
stock by saying it incentivizes
management to keep share prices high but
there's often no correlation take
recently departed Blackberry CEO John
Chen he made nearly $300 million during
his time in waterl despite the stock
tanking
47% during the same period the S&P 500
Rose a
168% whether a company is doing well or
doing poorly it seems the CEO's salary
just goes up and up year after year the
list of CEOs only had four women on it
tied with the number of people named
Mark and Scott with the marks making on
average 7 million more Carolyn than the
women did all right Mackenzie gray in
Ottawa thanks for that a lot of drivers
are pinching pennies to pay for gas
there's some relief coming up what's
fueling price changes at pumps across
Canada
Canada's largest airline has been ranked
last for ontime flights in North America
Air Canada landed 63% of its flights on
time last year the worst among the
continent's 10 largest Airlines the
score was 5% below the airlines in
second and third place both lowcost
carriers in the US well if driving is an
option Canadians are seeing some relief
at the pump compared to this time last
year but as of this week Alberta and
Manitoba have had a major shift in the
cost of gas Heather uck West looks at
what's driving prices in the Prairies
and what every Canadian driver can
expect this
year it's a gift for Manitoba drivers to
start out the new year I would say that
would take it from $130 a day to maybe $
100 so that's $30 savings per day uh and
you do the month on that it's it's it's
nice
effective January 1st that province's 14
cents a liter provincial pump tax has
disappeared gone for a six-month holiday
a move designed to help residents with
inflation I'm excited you know Manitoba
needed a
break a break that's come to an end in
Alberta I'm not super impressed you know
it's last thing we kind of kind of need
right now after a nearly 2year PA
Alberta's provincial pump tax was
reinstated at the start of the year
though at a lower rate 9 cents a liter
now instead of 13 It's Made Me kind of
think of maybe my next vehicle might be
a hybrid right I don't think I'm ready
for full electric yet even after
reinstating its pump tax Alberta still
has the lowest fuel costs in the country
with Saskatchewan and the newly
provincial fuel taxfree Manitoba close
behind elsewhere Canadians pay anywhere
from 15 to to 50 cents more a liter no
matter where in Canada you're filling up
chances are you're paying less at the
pumps today than you were this time last
year and that's because globally the
price of oil per barrel has fallen
though energy Watchers warn that could
soon change some of the main factors to
to worry about are things like well
whether or not the war in the Middle
East uh winds down somewhat or ramps up
somewhat and even with it the extra
shipping cost the people are now
incurring because they're avoiding that
particular area tax holiday or not
Canadians are likely to pay more to fill
up before 2024 is through Heather YX
West Global News
Calgary just ahead how Nova scotians are
still searching for answers after a
wildfire devastated The
Province more more than 7 months after a
wildfire tore through parts of Nova
Scotia many are still working to rebuild
their future the destructive Blaze forc
thousands to flee and cause millions in
damage but those affected still have few
answers as to what caused it as Heidi
petk explains recent Revelations have
some calling on officials to be more
forthcoming with
information Jerry hi it's Greg White uh
I have appliances it's moveing day for
Greg
white as workers haul a new fridge and
stove into his new home after the one he
lived in for 25 years on this same lot
was destroyed in last year's Nova Scotia
wildfires I feel great but tired he's
the first of those who lost their homes
in this subdivision to get this far the
key is uh you look for a win a day a
small win even if it's check in the mail
that's a win when your life's upside
down the lives of more than 16,000 Nova
Vis scotians were upended by fire
evacuations and in the Halifax area 150
homes burned down even as those
homeowners move forward in this new year
there are still questions about just how
the fire started the police
investigation quietly closed last fall
something the public didn't know until a
residents group recently released the
results of an access to information
request documents in which the RCMP said
the fire started as a result of quote
extinguished Embers from a small outdoor
patio fireplace but found no criminal
code offense noted the matter is now in
the hands of the province no one from
the group that requested this
information could do an interview today
but a representative tells me they're
very concerned officials didn't come
forward with these details earlier
leaving them with so many questions on
top of everything else the agencies
involved in the investigations that are
completed need to make themselves
available uh for for questioning there's
a lot of rumors and hearsay and stuff
like that but you know you you just
can't wallow on those sort of things it
would be nice to have an acknowledgement
of uh responsibility uh for
sure as another truck backs into his
driveway white says he's trying his best
now to focus on moving on as he finishes
moving in this week Heidi pachic Global
News Hammond's Plains Nova
Scotia the man behind the lens next how
Peter magani courageously documented
Decades of
apartheid the role that Nelson Mandela
played in guiding South Africa out of
the aptide era is well known but behind
Mandela's public presence South Africans
like photographer Peter magubane were
risking their lives and their freedom to
capture the violence and Injustice
magani died on Monday at the age of of
91 Eric Sorenson looks at the life of a
man whose work behind the lens spoke
volumes apartheid in South Africa was
racial discrimination at its most brutal
Peter magani was among the photographers
who put their lives in danger to
Chronicle the struggle of blacks for
equality magani sometimes hid his camera
in a loaf of bread to take pictures
still he was arrested imprisoned and
beaten the death of the legend
Dr Mak on the South African broadcasting
corporation's coverage he was remembered
for his work at the soo Uprising in 1976
magani had to persuade frightened
protesters to be photographed he engaged
them to say this picture will tell a
story not just now not just today but
forever and I think the preservation of
those photographs that he have taken we
will ensure that his legacy lives on
through the preservation of his his
various Works magani knew young Nelson
Mandela and when Mandela was released
from 27 years in prison magani became
his personal photographer when he came
out of prison he chose me to be a to be
his photographer to follow him up
wherever he's going you know and the the
body of world that I have here it is
because of him having selected me
magan's personal favorite was this
photograph of a black Nanny separated by
a bench from the white child she was
caring for and they had to take
tremendous risks to get any photographic
footage at all antia Raa says that
peaceful image in its own way tells the
appalling story of apartheid The Nanny
could not sit next to the child that
would be illegal and yet the image is so
sweet and caring but there is such
Menace uh behind what he's depicting
there like the photograph taken by his
colleague Sam enzima of a murdered child
that became the iconic image of the Soto
Uprising magan's images were
consequential at the time and they
remain an important Legacy in the fight
for justice in South Africa Eric senson
Global News
Toronto and that is global national for
this Tuesday night I'm Carolyn Jarvis
tonight's your candada is weaselhead
Flats Park in Calgary Alberta we love
seeing your Canada please email your
photos to viewers at
global.com thanks for watching Hope you
join us again tomorrow night see you
[Music]
then